-We'll be right back
with a performance
from GoldLink
featuring Flo Milli.
Stick around, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪♪ Dow-dow-dow-dow-dow-dow
♪♪ ...Or sit yourself down
♪♪ All the way from 215
to your town ♪♪
-I've hugged you before in life.
-We hugged like 10 minutes ago
-We hugged 10 minutes --
Yeah, we hugged today,
but it was off-camera.
But then I'm saying,
whenever I had you on the show
I don't know,
was it a handshake or a hug?
-You know, I typically do this
-You do that. [ Laughs ]
Oh, that's interesting.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, that's -- Yeah,
that's not what you do, do you
That feels like something
you would do.
-No, it's definitely --
When I do stand-up
and somebody introduces me
I go up and I say, "Thank you.
-That's a good bit. Yeah.
You haven't done that here
-No, but I'm happy
to do it next time.
And there will be a next time.
[ Audience cheering ]
-What if we do, like,
grab and then yank in?
You know those people?
-Well, I have
a partially-torn rotator cuff,
so I would say no.
-Oh.
You know what we do next time?
Ready for this?
-Yeah.
-You have to stand up.
-Oh.
Wait, my sound pack fell.
-That's alright.
We go in for the hug.
-Okay.
-Right?
-Yeah.
-We hug the other way.
So our heart --
-Hold on.
-So, this way, our hearts touch.
[ Audience "Aww"s ]
[ Laughter ]
-Why?
-Because the one was
meaningless, the other hug -
meaningless.
-Do you do that typically
with people?
-That's the thing --
you touch hearts, heartbeats
Our heartbeats
are beating with each other.
-But, I mean, do you typically
do that when you hug people?
You hug -- You do
a heart-to-heart?
-No.
-Oh. But just for me.
-I go the other way 'cause
it's traditional.
For you, heart-to-heart.
-Oh, thank you.